did you know that statistically speaking
part one of JoJo's Bizarre Adventure is
exactly 33% more enjoyable after you've
hit the subscribe button for the new
world review which gives you the added
benefit of having regular Jojo content
uploaded straight into your YouTube feed
and yes that first part was a blatant
lie but do it anyway cuz clicking things
is fun hello and welcome to the new
world review your source for everything
anime and manga and today I would like
to discuss the near insurmountable
challenge presented to all new and
prospective fans of JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure which is the seemingly simple
task of picking up the series to begin
with now at this point it's undeniable
that JoJo's Bizarre Adventure is a
phenomenon with 126 volumes of manga to
its name as well as a mighty four
seasons of anime in covering the first
five parts of the series and you know a
slew of other extended media so all it
may have taken a while the series now
has clear global resonance especially in
regards to meme culture which we will
get into in this video for sure but
despite all of this I don't think I've
ever had a more difficult time with any
other series than I have had attempting
to summon the desire to actually pick up
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure and I don't
think I'm necessarily alone in that
experience because Jojo is a perfect
storm of road blocks that can
relentlessly assault too casual reader
or watcher and just turn so many people
away in its early stages or even before
they even embark on their journey and
it's not as simple as saying something
like yeah look you just got to get
through phantom blood and then
everything will be a-okay because the
barrier for entry is much more severe
than that which is what we are here to
discuss so before even actually engaging
in part 1 of Jojo
there are a couple of very core problems
the prospective fans will be faced with
one of which is the very simple issue of
length JoJo's Bizarre Adventure is a
series that has been running ever since
1987 which makes it one of the rare
ongoing manga series in the world that
is even older than me and that comes
with a very rich history but also an
ass-ton of chapters and/or episodes
which for some people may be incredibly
exciting sort of like a new mountain to
scale but for an awful lot of others
especially the majority of people Mayan
generation being Millennials by the way
I'm not that old but for younger
generations this can be a bit of an
unappealing proposition when you could
instead spend that time engulfing
multiple other shorter series and in
this regard I speak from the perspective
of being a longtime one piece fan I
remember when I was in high school
trying to get my friends into the series
and the moment they found out that it
was gasp over 400 chapters long they
lost all ambition to give it a go cut to
modern day and one piece is rapidly
approaching the 1000 chapter mark and
that issue has sadly only become more
difficult and Jojo is very much in the
same boat because at this stage it also
sits at well over 900 chapters as well
as an impressive mountain of episodes to
go through if that's your jam I mean
just looking at the crunchyroll Jojo
page for the first time was like wow
there is a lot to this series of strange
stuff and I just don't know if I have
the time to commit to it
but then if you want to give it a go
anyway well what do you do I guess you
check out the first few episodes to form
a solid impression of the series and
then you run into oh dear God no but
before we hop into that Jojo has another
big problem from a completely outside of
perspective which is the lack of a solid
brand identity and I'll go back to one
piece as an example to illustrate this
because even someone who is in no way a
fan of the series will understand the
core of one piece they'll know Luffy or
they'll at least know his image as well
as the selection of the straw hats and
they will have an innate understanding
that the primary concept of this world
is piracy and adventure helmed by these
figures and one piece is of course much
more complicated than that but it's an
easy constant to grasp onto meanwhile
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure does not have
this anchor seeing screenshots memes or
promotional material from the series
does not provide an outsider with an
overall impression because it is divided
into eight parts each with their own
protagonist and each with their own
genre of storytelling and the shifting
is most certainly one of the key
elements of charm in regards to Jojo but
on the outside it can appear muddled and
confusing I mean what is this series
about is it about energy fueled combat
is it about summoning monsters to do
your bidding
is it like a slice-of-life comedy or a
gangster drama or even a jaunt of two
best buddies in the Old West and the
answer is look it's all of that but
furthermore who the hell is Jojo is this
Jojo I see him a lot but who are all of
these guys who also seem to be called
JoJo's and look why is one of them a
sailor all of these are potential
roadblocks which in some cases yes may
spark interest to research the series
out of sheer intellectual curiosity but
in a lot of other cases it can lead to
thinking oh and we don't like thinking
because thinking takes effort so I do
think that Jojo suffers on the outside
from not having a clear value
proposition or a flagship figure to
grasp on to like one pieces monkey D
Luffy although another good comparison
might be Doctor Who actually because
that show has an incredibly rich
pedigree as the longest running sci-fi
program in human history and it
frequently changes its protagonist
through the concept of regeneration
however that individual always possesses
the undeniable identity that is
doctor no matter who is playing them and
it also has the stability of genre which
is sci-fi as well as many constants such
as the TARDIS time lords etc which
despite making radical changes to the
fabric of the show allows it to retain a
core identity that is something that I
feel is much more difficult and probably
impossible to achieve with Jojo and once
again I do think that only serves as an
advantage once you're into the series
and experiencing it but it is admittedly
one of the many reasons that kept me
from delving into it for the better part
of a decade because I just didn't know
what to expect from it well why I should
care and one other thing I need to
address before we start part one I go
there's a lot of this but when we're
discussing Outsiders I do need to talk
about the meme culture of the Jura fan
base after having gone through all eight
parts I was kind of shocked at just how
far JoJo's Bizarre Adventure has
infiltrated the world of mainstream
memes I mean apparently I was enjoying
Georgia references before I even realize
that they were Georgia references but
with that said the meme culture of Jojo
can sometimes I'd say often go a bit
overboard and really there are only so
many Kanodia does railroad arrows and
Roger all's that one can see before
being given quite an obnoxious and
off-putting impression of not only at
the fan base but the series itself as a
result and this is a tough one because
I'm sure that these widespread memes
have done just as much good as they have
harmed by propelling Jojo further into
the world but at the same time before I
properly dealt into the series I already
felt like I was kind of over it because
I had been overly saturated with memes
it's like that intriguing psychological
phenomena that occurs when all of your
friends highly recommend a show for you
to watch and then you have this moment
of oh my god I am so sick of hearing
about how I have to watch this random
show that I actively want to avoid it
that is how I felt after seeing my fair
share of Georgia memes and I would
definitely definitely call them another
barrier to entry in any case let's leave
these early and numerous roadblocks
aside and begin to discuss those that
actually emerge during the series itself
which we start out very very strongly
and by which I mean quit poorly with
part 1 being phantom blood so after
seeing all sorts of fantastical
out-of-context images and scenes from
the lifespan of the series this is what
the initial viewer is met with which is
in essence kind of a stock standard to
mediocre horror action piece from the
1980s
there's no Jotaro who is probably the
most recognizable protagonist as an
outsider nor are there any stands it's
just a couple of dudes fighting vampires
in a painfully plain series battles that
eventually culminates in my favorite
part of phantom blood which is when it
ends and I never have to work
again this is our first foray into Jojo
and not only does it not live up to
anything we've seen out of context it
doesn't even live up to its own name of
being a Bizarre Adventure in reality it
is such a standard story just featuring
bulkier than average men none of which
present characters of any depth as well
as largely meaningless antagonists who
serve only to provide the technically
necessary action of an action harpies
phantom blood is the thing that stopped
me from properly delving into Jojo for
so so long I tried to get into the
series three times two of which were
with the anime and one with the manga
and on all three occasions I stopped
during phantom blood because I felt like
my time was just being wasted and the
sad thing is it's not that long either
nine anime episodes and five manga
volumes but nine episodes is such a
weird number because generally I'll give
something you know maybe three to five
episodes to pique my interest before
dropping it so 9 is it's a surprisingly
huge ask I mean that point you're
looking at what just over three and a
half hours of anime yeah that's a lot
especially when you're not enjoying it
and some people have come up with like a
fun solution for this which is to skip
part one and then immediately begin with
part two or in some cases even part
three which I will emphasize should
never be done
part one whilst underwhelming on its own
is the foundation for everything to come
after it without the knowledge of these
mundane events and characters the effect
of future parts especially two and three
are heavily minimized and that becomes a
roadblock of its own because if you
aren't equipped with the history the
chances of losing interest in events you
don't fully understand skyrockets so
you're left with this horrendous
situation where you must force your way
through part one for maximum enjoyment
of everything else and I think that the
best solution to this I throw it so far
is to sit down and just make a day of
watching it with friends so you can keep
each other entertained instead of just
being bored and giving up here's the
thing though let's say you get through
phantom blood and to be quite frank you
deserve a medal for doing that then you
move on to battle tendency and look you
probably enjoy it if for the only reason
that it's not phantom blood and then you
think that you're clear from the jojo
road box yeah well you're wrong because
along comes part three stardust
crusaders and it has some well it has
some changes it would like to make a lot
of changes firstly remember hum on no
you don't it's all about stands now and
not only that remember story nope no
story this time around it's just a
monster of the week series which won't
truly progress any kind of story until
the final few episodes and finally do
you remember character development oh
not anymore because aside from the admit
my tea polnareff none of our main
characters are going to learn anything
or change in any way as a result of this
48 episode run 48 episodes and to be
quite frank this may be the most massive
roadblock in all of Georgia primarily
because it requires you as a reader or a
watcher to completely change your
thinking and expectations of the series
because parts 1 & 2 had trained you
interviewing Jojo has an ongoing story
with actual progress to be made and now
you've had to switch gears and look at
it as more of an isolated anthology of
stories each exploring a particular
power which are admittedly very
interesting but it's not the value
proposition that we had been sold up
until now luckily for part three though
it does contain some of the most
likeable characters within Jojo at large
and that was how I was able to get
through it the interactions between the
group were pure gold
however after 24 episodes I was starting
to get very very frustrated that nothing
was actually happening and I've heard
from many people in my comment section
that just stopped watching or reading
during part 3 because it is such a
sizable piece of story because you know
if it's 9 episodes the phantom blood
well you can just blast through that
however according to mathematics 48 is a
much larger number than 9 and thus will
require you know a certain degree of
patience to get through even if you're
committed to just letting go and
enjoying the ride here's where the good
news finally comes in there after
Stardust Crusaders it's pretty smooth
sailing through diamond is unbreakable
and golden wind in which Eric you really
starts to perfect his stand storytelling
formula and by this time you should also
be accustomed to our keys habit of
changing up the series genre so the
slice of life form end of part 4 and the
Italian mafia story of part 5 are taken
in and adapted with significantly less
narrative shock although I can't deny
that each of those do present a
potential roadblock as well because if
you're not interested in slice of life
for a mafia drama and that's going to
heavily detract from your experience
going forward but the next potential big
roadblock I see is part 6 being start
ocean which I would say is a barrier for
anime fans at this point because to
continue with Jojo they need to delve
into the manga in part 6 as well it's
interesting and likeable enough but it
is certainly not peak Jojo in any way
shape or form and unfortunately a lot of
fans just stop right here due to not
having the drive to finish stone ocean
which for many of them is their very
first Jojo manga experience and that's
very unfortunate because it's just one
stop away from the glorious steel ball
run but if you've already made it to
that point in this video probably no
longer holds any relevance fear because
you're seven parts deep now and you're
well aware of what Jojo is and I hope
that you are now enjoy
your time reading Jojo Lyon but the
journey to get there like the roadblocks
are insane I don't think this series
ever lets up in terms of throwing
something new your way and something
that could very potentially turn you off
it but that said JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure still has this undeniable
charm that seems to see people through I
mean it certainly worked for me and it
will probably work for you as well so
long as you hang in there and give it a
chance but what do you guys think please
do leave your thoughts on how easy or
not it is to hop into JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure in the comments below and if
you're keen am on Jojo content and
please do check out some of my other
videos and even subscribe to the channel
for regular Jojo Wanda delivered
straight to your YouTube feed this has
been the new world review and I'll see
you next time